fox news reports biden's cancer claim
shocks twitter users either the biggest
bombshell or biggest gaff i think it's a
fair assessment but what i want to talk
about in relation to joe biden and
donald trump is this up here in the top
right the news guard certification
as of july 18th the daily beast has been
reinstated as true
real news
and fox news has been downrank
fascinating and so the reason is
they say that fox doesn't regularly
correct errors because there's a bunch
of stuff that tucker carlson's put out
that is factually incorrect and i think
news guard is actually right about that
but there's an interesting question in
outside of just fox news
in the presidency
let me show you this news guard says
while former president trump did claim
in a february 28 2021 fox news interview
that he requested that congress
authorized ten thousand national
guardsmen to bolster capital security
before january 6 there has been no
corroboration of this claim
why is it
that when there is something that is for
the narrative they can choose to ignore
the president
whenever whatever the narrative is they
will ignore if donald trump came out and
admitted to wrongdoing they would say
well trump confirmed it if donald trump
comes out and admits to something or
says something happened that would be
bad for their narrative they say it's
fake news
how does newsguard decide that the word
of the president of the united states is
not good enough to accept
meanwhile joe biden can come out and
says say he has cancer to the world
and it's also considered less than
credible now that's a very serious
problem if the president is outright
overtly lying and the media just says oh
yeah we don't take the president's word
for it i can understand that you want
verification yet if you google search
biden confirms you'll see a bunch of
story about biden confirming the cost of
you know biden confirms unprecedented g7
move on putin set to cost billions how
do we know it's the president his words
meaningless we need well biden's also
said he has cancer why should i believe
anything why should the media be allowed
to claim that biden's confirmed
something
and then say oh but his cancer is not
true how many times has biden come out
and said something nonsensical and then
the white house has come out and said
actually what really happened is this
when donald trump says something they
say he's lying about it you can't trust
him
it's it's it's a nonsense reality where
the media decides when the president's
telling the truth
how does that make sense
my thing is i mean you guys you do the
journalist thing
i think the real question is when did it
stop did you have that ethical
basis of unbiased right i'm just gonna
report the facts as they are like i'm
not gonna tell i'm not gonna put any any
lenience on it like this is what he said
you make the decision whether or not it
is why does it have to have all the
other context behind it and we don't do
it either way you look at it like cnn
watchers don't get mad when cnn does it
but they get mad when fox does it and
vice versa
i still believe the problem in america
as much as we talk about the system it's
it's not it's not the system it's
americans
and i love the country i ran for office
i ran for office in frederick i ran for
county council at large
around actually the year
last governor race when the mood in the
country was significantly anti-trump and
democrats came out and drove iran as a
republican because in maryland you got
to pick right
i knocked on over a hundred thousand
doors
do you know how many times i discussed
my platform
how many
one time huh one time ironically it was
a older man wearing a bernie sanders
shirt smoking weed in his retirement wow
we had a good 45 minute conversation
but i every door i knocked on it was
what are you running ass and if i was
running what you wanted me to run ass
you got my vote like you didn't even
know what i was you didn't no clue what
i was what my platform was
and
if i wasn't what you wanted me to be you
slam the door in my face and walk crazy
yeah well i think at one time in our
country your party affiliation was
shorthand for the things that you
believed in your values not just
politically but culturally and that's
shifted so much i mean the senator from
i'm forgetting his name right now from
oregon who just lost he's the first
incumbent uh elected official from
oregon to lose a race since the 1980s he
said you know i'm a moderate democrat
and basically our party has been
controlled by socialists so it has moved
away from me i know that we hear
conservatives say this on many different
directions i mean you'll talk to
libertarians who say i don't feel the
way my parents felt socially i identify
fiscally as conservative but i'm
socially left i think that
we
are coming out of a day and age where
you could believe someone's political
affiliation
to be something of substance whereas now
you really do have to do the work to ask
someone and no one wants to do that
especially you know when you're suddenly
you know i think it's great that you
went door-to-door but like if you're you
have kids in the house you're doing
something else you don't want to be like
well how do you feel about this these
are the issues that are important
important to me you want the shorthand
you want to say oh you've you're
affiliated with my team that's good
enough and that just doesn't really
function in today's world i mean the
real rubber meets the road and no one
pays attention to this
is the local elections
you know everybody's hung up on congress
and president but hey if your property
tax is going up that's the county
council guy yeah right and when we went
controller yeah and when we went to
debates you know and i'm running for the
entire county there were like 10 people
in the audience
and it's like you guys really
we're not involved and we have the
liberty honestly to not be involved
because for the most part people like
listen man like i'm doing okay
you know i'm commit i'm eating i'm not
worried about whether or not i'm going
to get mugged i'm not worried about
armed insurrection right now so
who really cares about tom that owns a
shoe shop that's running for county
council but that's who makes makes and
breaks your life really this is why it
always irks me a little bit when people
say you know vote for me for congress
and i'll clean up this town or things of
that nature and i'm like no you won't
you're going to go to dc and represent
there are you know us to them
if you want to clean up your your town
your neighbor you got to vote local and
the most important thing especially for
populists is voting local because you
know some people are in favor of a
convention of states some aren't but you
want you want to set the rules you want
to change the laws in your state maybe
you're pro-choice maybe you're pro-life
that's your state reps
you're one the the left might be
wondering why you know texas is banning
abortion well the state-level
politicians the one who do that not
congress
but all anyone ever talks about is
national level stuff it's a mistake the
governor of new hampshire really upset
people when he said he wasn't going to
run for senate he was going to stay in
new hampshire because he believed his
work was he could do more for the people
of new hampshire as governor than as
senator because the senator you end up
spending most of your time in washington
i mean
if you it's it's not that there isn't a
place for both but i think being
involved locally is really
where you make a huge difference it's
unappreciated i think the real catch-22
is that i think
i'm willing to i really feel that 85 to
90 of people that go into politics
honestly initially go into politics for
very very good reasons very honest
reasons ethical reasons they want to
make a difference the problem is the
longer you play that game the more you
become institutionalized with what it
takes to get something to actually be
accomplished i think a lot of people
lose sight of how complicated even a
state level bill is much less trying to
pass a law that's going to affect the
entire united states and that's why we
get these bills that are
ungodly links that have you know i'm
going to make something up at the time
you know
we want to pet puppies it's thrown in
with hey let's give 20 billion dollars
to ukraine but we lead with let's pet
puppies right right and it's like one
paragraph of we had puppies and then 5
000 pages of how we're going to strip
money from the working class to fund a
war in ukraine but the problem the
headline is you know senator votes
against pet puppies yes yes every time
they do
he'll be like i voted no on this little
like how could you vote no against
puppies and i'm like because that
provision said we blow him up afterwards
but then no one wants to listen to that
part either that part's boring yeah it's
always bothered me that people get so
frustrated with federal politics i'm
like you need to look
at your next-door neighbor you need to
look at who's running for city council
who your mayor is going to be at who's
running your school board these are
important questions that affect you way
more than the president ever will
honestly and people don't want to put
the work in the federal government is
there we can complain about them it's
not that big a deal sure they taxes
whatever but for the most part they
leave us alone they tax though yeah oh i
know but if they if you actually do want
to make a positive difference in your
culture you need to run like you did or
you need to at least very least pay
attention to what's going on in your
community part of why national politics
is easier to get involved in this
because it's televised a lot of it's
televised we see watch c-span and crap
like that but like local politics isn't
televised enough for people to like
because they don't want to go to the
meeting people just don't want to they
want to stay at home and witness it from
their tv if they can i think it is but
people people have only watched national
news so it's like when you turn nowadays
with the internet you're not turning on
your local news to see a local like
public access people are turning on
c-span for congress or they're
pulling up cnn that only talks about the
fed or federal level i mean it's a
reality now
speaking broad generalizations like
in today's society and economy both
parents have to work
your kids are involved in 15 different
things so they're going right from piano
practice to football practice to ballet
practice they got a busier schedule than
most adults now and so these debates and
things they don't take place to 5 30 6
30 at night on a thursday afternoon well
that's little timmy soccer practice
what's the likelihood that i'm gonna
come to that you know and that's where
you lose it is that like calvinism the
idea that if everyone's working they
can't do anything else
i could be mixing things up because
communism was a sect of christianity
it could be um like puritanism maybe it
was like this idea
keep everybody busy toiling the fields
so that they can't do anything else
if everybody has to work 24 7 they can
never revolt you don't have any trouble
i think is what the thought is
no one can get into mischief or be lazy
or do something like that if that's like
the road to kim jong-un's keep everyone
starving and then they won't revolt kind
of mentality but the other problem here
now we saw this in maryland and i i i
was going off about this today because i
still can't believe
they
push cox through in the primary
but
at every measurable thing that you can
look at just about maryland is
substantially better off than it was
before governor hogan took office and
because one or i hate the term rhino it
drives me nuts because anytime somebody
disagrees with one thing that a
republican said he's he or she is now
automatically a rhino and it's really
decimated a lot of times the republican
party in my opinion but they go in here
and they make this big push for him and
i'm like dude
you're never going to agree
with everything that everyone says i
guarantee you every one of us disagrees
on something at this table right but
what you have to look at is what is the
overall picture are we much better than
we were there and then at the same time
like i was arguing with the guys like
you know he's talking about descendants
i was like
desantis couldn't come here and win in
maryland and governor hogan couldn't
take maryland policy to florida and get
anything done it's two completely
different electorates and no one wants
to acknowledge that and it's like yo
like listen if if you love descent it's
that much in florida which i think it i
went to daytona during bike week and
covet and they were having a blast
move to florida that's that's your
solution but if you're going to stay in
maryland what are what are your choices
you got your choices of having
improvement where he took us from like
i think 46th in
uh business an economy to six over eight
years that's massive
why would you not be happy about it i
want to ask this question because um i'm
not sure if it was alex jones or someone
i think it might have been alex implying
that joe biden would get sick and then
they would replace him or bring in
kamala because joe biden can't run so
the question that we've been asking
right now
is joe biden going to run for another
term he says yes i don't know if i
believe it because you've got all these
democrats lining up you've even got
prominent democrats outright saying to
journalists
we don't think biden's going to run we
don't want them to run polls are showing
they don't want biden to run so how
could biden run against the will of the
democrat voters against the will of
other democrats and in the face of all
the democrats running against them but
if that's the case
how do you get biden out now
well some have suggested he'll be he'll
get sick or he is sick or something will
happen to his son i'm wondering what you
guys think about this you know just just
bouncing back to the cancer thing but
taking in this direction
could it be that this is meant to be
sort of just um
a little
little little sprinkling of the biden is
very sick thing so that
when finally the time comes let's say
you know like uh
other presidents who have feigned
illness yes he's sick and he needs to
step down and kamala's moving in i think
no that it wasn't intentional only
because of their responses like no no he
meant he used to have it and and but i
think it is an indication that he's sick
and that they will pivot into that as it
comes up i think he'll actually run
he'll be on stage with other democrats
that are running and he'll be like you
know what you're right you're the one
that needs to take the torch and get
like his 60 million followers to just
clap and smile and turn towards the next
person in line whoever i mean i wonder
if it's going to be opposite i wonder if
they're going to be like okay joe so
you're not going to run next anymore so
just just keep it cool and he's going to
be out somewhere and he's like yeah so
when i run for re-election they're going
to be like what do we do because we
don't actually want to support this guy
anymore but i think the fact is joe
biden's old he is sick i don't know if
he has cancer but imagine what would
happen pr wise for the democrats if joe
biden was on stage in a debate and
collapsed
that would be bad for biden but good for
democrats it's so funny that he said i
have cancer and you were like i don't
know if he has cancer like you just
don't know anyone that came to me and
told me that i would believe them why
would you think they were lying to you
that's crazy no it's crazy right why do
you think it would be good for democrats
it would create a whole lot of sympathy
it would give biden an exit which would
be honorable an honorable exit uh they
would say you know biden sacrificed
himself to stop trump that kind of that
kind of stuff or sacrifice his health
they would ham it up they would say
here's a man who stepped out of
retirement after he lost his son knowing
he was sick because he knew america
needed a leader
and then you know he gets sick and maybe
he doesn't die maybe just collapses that
would that's the perfect exit for biden
it's the perfect positive pr spin
so i'm not saying it will happen i don't
know it gives you kind of like a martyr
like heroic like exit
but i don't think they want camilla i
mean i think which i still don't
understand how she got the the nod as
the vp i i agree
but if
just because she steps up as vp doesn't
mean she runs in 2024 she could she'll
go out there and let's say
hypothetically joe biden faints you know
on stage or something at some kind of
town hall and they're like oh no and
then he's like i can't run you know the
american people you're going to need
someone younger
kamala steps in they remember when they
announced the 25th amendment panel and
everyone was like they're trying to get
trump out and then people like no no
it's for biden like they were preparing
to remove fighting yeah
so they did that
and a lot of people said that you know
that's what's going to happen it could
still happen
but i didn't get sick faints kamala hara
says i'm going to come in and i'm going
to take over as president
but i'm going to step aside and let
someone else run i'm not just sticking
correctly she does a lot of this motion
well you know i'll do my best
we the collective knowing what we know
we're going to do what we've always done
today
and i'm going to nominate gadden for be
president
i just i think she is i i still don't
understand like obviously the people
that put this stuff together have more
experience with it than i do but of all
the people you could have picked i mean
she wasn't even popular with what they
were going for on the base so
the dnc picks them yeah and they pick
biden and they're going to pick the next
one and they'll probably tell biden we
picked this person now just support them
or something like that
kamala harris check the right boxes i
guess yep diversity yeah diversity women
of color diversity but you couldn't find
anyone else i mean like even
that's i'm a fan yeah
right she doesn't she doesn't think
inside their box i mean tulsi gabbard is
too independent for them i i don't think
i think kamala harris knew this was her
shot she couldn't have run her president
i mean she wasn't going to get the
nomination on her own i gotta say you
know when we were we were talking about
aoc she went on colbert and she made up
this mishmash hodgepodge of civil war
history that was just hilariously
brilliant and uh
it was it was a chat move it was the the
ultimate chad move to go and just go on
national television and just make up
history and you got to think about
kamala harris
you know when she does these speeches
that are considered auto text like like
you know predictive text filler
that's also a chat move
she's going up on stage knowing she's
saying nothing and people clap for her
it's just like
the ultimate mockery of your own
constituents
and she just throws that cackle behind
it and it's just
like nails on the chalkboard it's the
worst thing
i mean she has incredibly low
approval rating she's not popular at all
i don't know how she
but who do you pick though who did you
take if you could if you could right now
your choice you got you you gotta go you
gotta go biden you gotta go her who do
you wanna run in the nation oh her
kamala okay i'd rather have a predictive
text generation like a literal
predictive text generator than either of
them but you know joe here's my fear
with joe biden
he's i think he's corrupt
but he's brain damaged so he might be
like i want i want to get a shipment
into
iran and you're like
iran do you mean iraq what no and then
they're like i guess we're going to be
shipping iran a bunch of military
supplies the president said so and
you're like whoa dude i get he wanted to
make money off this illicit deal but
he's having a weapon so when when when
biden accidentally said libya over and
over again i'm like imagine him in the
situation room like tell him to press
the button and they're bombing the wrong
country
at least kamala harris is corrupt but
she can speak properly you know what i
mean like they're both not all with it
but she's just a little bit more
cognitively with it i mean honestly
that's the point i hadn't really thought
about is like you know you get your
finger on the on the button you're just
digging begging me to hit it and then i
say the wrong place well we'll check it
out it's you know kamala and biden are
both corrupt but kamala lives on this
planet and wants to keep living on this
planet joe biden too but his brain
doesn't work so you know biden might
accidentally blow us up kamala doesn't
want to ruin she doesn't want to kill
the peasants who supply her with slave
labor you know what i mean the question
is though for me
who do you think
pulls the strengths
like i don't believe there's some
reptilian like if you know you go back
all of a sudden you pull the mask off
there's a lizard person there
but at the same time it's like
for you to have that much control is it
one person is it a group of people how
do you get to be in the group of people
like who is actually the one filling out
his note card saying hey say this and
then also repeat line i mean it may just
be
staffers
you know but that's scarier
that's like super scary i feel like
you'd want to take a critical look at
who is propping biden up because they
have so much influence right now
especially if he's not capable of like
saying no we're being like maybe i
shouldn't say that i mean this guy is
reading his stage directions the shadow
government is a 22 year old intern with
no governmental experience he's just
like um i guess biden should probably
say he doesn't want to blow up russia
he's in so deep hard he doesn't want to
get fired
and my experience with those interns is
they're not really happy i mean i've
been down to the capitol to testify for
stuff before and you know they literally
have which i've always thought it was
funny when they talk about minimum wage
and they've got a staffer that the door
literally opens into them in their
little office on the thing and they're
working 70 80 hours for like 12 bucks an
hour so he's mad he's angry and never
said you know what hey you know what i'm
gonna it's literally ron burgundy we're
gonna show him this guy he's putting on
the prompter and the end of quote repeat
the line yep he's bergen he's doing it
because he could say fu america that's
too heavy-handed it's too much but it
might catch that one
no he said repeat line repeat the line
that's that's bad crazy it's bad that's
bad
it's hard wow
well that's america for you i guess this
is what the american people wanted huh
they voted idiocracy
well i think it's a cult i think it's
the media i i i don't i think it's
epithelia for a lot of people they go
out and they just hit the d but i think
they were able to get a lot of people in
a cult
you know yeah oh yeah you asked why is
the media when at what point did the
media stop serving the the transparency
and start serving an agenda i my thought
the answer that is when we go to war
whenever the country goes to war the
media apparatus
rallies to start printing propaganda war
propaganda we really went to war not
technically but in 2001 when we hit iraq
and then it's never stopped it's we're
still in this turmoil and now i guess
you could say we're out of iraq we're
still occupying or we're out of
afghanistan we're still occupying iraq
and now russia's there's a war between
the ukraine and russia that the
government seems to want to be involved
in what blows my mind is the shift from
9 12.
because i took i took the first i
responded to the pentagon on the night
on the terrorist attacks and secured the
pentagon and then ultimately took the
first team in to start doing remains
removal and when we would leave the
pentagon to go back to do shift changes
you just see everybody i mean honking
the horn waving the flag everybody
unified
and in such a relatively short period of
time we just become
just really two almost warring tribes
and like literally they've had people
say you know you might have to fight
your neighbor
right so
for me it's like
when did we make that major major shift
and was it just because the news went to
a 24-hour cycle and now they need to
sell commercial space or they're only
going to put the most deficit divisive
angry rhetoric up because it keeps
people engaged or is it something more
than that i think after the uh 9 11
there's a lot of muslim hate and that
created the tribes and this was like
christian muslim american and afghani
whatever and then it slowly morphed with
social media started finding out how
much more popular their clicks were when
you got angry but at some point
people
got turned against each other
republicans and democrats it was like
when trump got elected they used that as
a catalyst media apparatus but i don't
know if it's an external thing you know
it's not all american nbc news is not
all american all the time like there's
people involved in that that aren't
american
um i don't know i don't know that
there's necessarily a date but it was
like around 2012 or 2013.
i did social media and then when you
looked at that side of the house where
you get the echo chambers where now your
algorithms only show you the exact same
people that believe exactly what you
believe and then you actually go like
hey
man
i'm super right and everybody backs me
up but because you don't have like you
don't have the
town halls the community engagement
anymore covet made it worse because
everybody was literally confined to
their house and so now we just become
further and further instead of i think
jordan peterson is the one that talks
about it is that people are inherently
born with a he calls them red and blue
like inherently a left world view and
inherently a right world view and up
until social media that was actually
good because you had to come together
and they had to have conversation and
compromise and so we actually kind of
got a little bit centrist in miller road
but now because we don't really have to
interact with each other in person that
often anymore and we have these echo
rooms on social media like the divide is
just huge and that's what makes it scary
for things like is it possible
for us to see something like a civil war
or something where we actually have this
big fight coming down the pipe i do
think so thanks for checking out this
clip from timcast irl come hang out live
monday through friday at 8 pm eastern
time super chat we'll even answer some
of your questions if you want to check
out the after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up monday through thursday at 11
pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time